tell me for people
for people out there listening tell give
me like a like a brief little background
on like who you are where you came from
and what you do like what are you all
about
so basically i was talking get a little
bit so basically i'm from jersey
originally yeah pert damboy real close
to uh
elizabeth newark around that area and
what i do is i just
buy and sell anything but mostly uh real
estate
vintage cards baseball cards stuff like
that
jewelry watches well anything that has a
liquid value
so growing up i was born in 1970
my uncle used to own hardware stores
liquor stores
so i was always brought up in the grind
you know what i mean
yeah because in reality
there's really no money in school and
back in those days
back in 76 carter was the president we
had a you know we had a gasoline
shortage
you know um the interest rates were like
20
so the only way to make money was to
have cash just like today
but the world's changed a little bit but
so the buying and selling game is where
the money's at
so that being said i moved out here in
19 um
i would say like 1989 1990.
i had to get out of jersey because it
was just nothing but trouble
so when i came here my first job
actually was um
i was a custodian at a high school in
brandon
making six dollars an hour walking seven
eight miles a day
to go to work it was my favorite time of
my life
the grind so then i bought a little flea
market booth
in seffner florida baseball cards from
this lady for two thousand dollars
within
two three months you know just kept
stacking my bread
had about twenty thirty thousand i went
to tampa i bought a little baseball card
shop in
fiesta plaza then i started hitting the
country going to the big shows
buying sellings i've always been a big
sports fan
and then in the meantime you know i
would only work maybe
friday saturday sunday due to grind and
then you know i meet people by their
collections just buy out their tables
and then one thing led to another and
then you just deal with different
businesses jewelry stores
pawn shops um furniture
bail bonds real estate
and real estate's a good hustle because
it has a lot of zeros at the end
so if you buy something let's say you
buy a pair of sneakers for 500 bucks and
you sell them for 800.
sounds cool we're only making 300 what
are you gonna do with 300
right you buy a house for a hundred
thousand you flip it for a buck thirty
you just made 30 g's
so the bottom line is to make money you
just got to be well versed well-rounded
and you got to be able to pull that
trigger immediately
because in any game nobody wants to deal
with a procrastinator
it's either you're in or you're out
there's really no in between bro when i
first met you
i think it was like yesterday was two
days ago i think
you reminded me instantly of like you
had you were like just tony soprano to
me like you were you're
you're so much energy you hustle your
hands are in so many different things so
many different types of businesses
you have sneaker stores
scattered throughout the state you have
this a warehouse full of trading cards
like how
how much money worth of trading like
baseball cards and basketball cards do
you have
so let's get back to the beginning where
your question like the like the sneaker
store
yeah that belongs to a friend of mine
and i was like involved in the beginning
and i still am
a little involved it's it's a slower
pace fast-paced game let me tell you
what i mean by that then we'll get to
the cards
it's a hustle it's a grind and you're
making 50 60 a pair you got to push a
lot of pairs
you got to do a lot of work you got to
pay high rents and you know
it's just it's a good game for somebody
who's looking to make a million a year
you know what i mean
i still work with the same people but
the trading card the baseball cards this
is
that's a hustle i like but to answer
your question the value of what i have
several million but i constantly buy and
sell every day
uh the baseball card game is something
that's really come up a lot
because it's um it's an asset without a
paper trail
and everybody's interested in it like i
was telling you it's sort of like
artwork
but on a different level because
everybody knows about sports
and everybody wants to get involved
what's the
number one most valuable card that you
own you know i own some psa
jordan 10 rookie cards you know they
were bringing like 750 to 800 000
you know they've cooled off a little bit
to about four to five hundred thousand
basically because you know it's a new
asset
class that that the smart money's coming
into
but you know i have 1988 flair
basketball i probably have 800 created
packs
you know the tens are three four
thousand each
um but i have a lot of different stuff
you know from mickey mantle to ty cobb
to babe ruth to jordan
you know i don't really do much with the
newer stuff because
they're very volatile and i'm not
interested in losing money
and you do all these transactions on
ebay with the cards yeah we'll buy
collections you know a guy called me up
hey i got this collection 1957 tops
baseball set just
use that as an example so we look at
what they have okay cool we just add it
up figure it out just buy it from them
then we get the cards graded we'll just
you know whatever we do with it you know
you just crack the collections down
that's what i did for numerous years i
should travel the country
you know spend a few thousand by you
know 100 000 here 200 000 there get some
graded
wholesale some retail it's just a
fast-paced business
have you so are you going to buy or sell
any cars today like is this a daily
thing you do yeah daily
you're you're are you like riding the
market
day-to-day are you are there any cards
any things that you hold
hold out on long term definitely like
the best cards to hold are the vintage
cards
like you want to buy stuff that's going
to go up in value based
based on the story of the player like
let me give an example
babe ruth he's probably the greatest
baseball player ever to play the game
so you have a lot of people that are
looking for that card
and a lot there's more collectors than
product
so the grading company is great from a
scale of one to ten
and then they have a population report
how how many cards have been slapped in
certain grade
like i i buy cards now let's take an
example
for ten thousand dollars that i sold for
a thousand three years ago
so you want to buy the old cards and the
newer cards
they have a lot of hype because a lot of
young people who are flipping crypto and
and making money in the stock market
this is what they're seeing but at the
same time
when you're spending three four hundred
thousand dollars on a card of a guy
who's been in the league three years you
don't really know the outcome of his
career
so you're basically uh making a bet like
me i don't make bets if it's not a
guarantee
i just don't want to deal with it right
that makes sense
you know i get in the prop i get in the
product cheap i try to buy as many as i
can
and i the more i buy the more they're
worth because i'm the one that's going
to drive up the price
what other kind of businesses are you in
well i dabble in anything that makes
money you know what i mean if i like
look yesterday a friend of mine hit me
up
that he's uh he's a realtor he's a good
friend of mine he's actually
selling a property of mine for like four
million dollars and he hit me with this
eureka coin he said brian look at this
eureka coin
it was a dollar nineteen billion talk
get a little bit closer to them it was a
dollar and yeah you can pull it to you
it was a dollar ninety and i think the
last night he hit me up at about 2 p.m
yesterday
and the last i checked about an hour ago
was at 5 and 50 cents
really yeah look i don't even heard of
eureka coin neither did i
well 99 of the things today i've never
heard of
see that's why you know i jump in and
out you know and then
i'll play the wave and you know i'll day
trade and i'll make 70 80 transactions
in an hour
due to the fact that you never go broke
on a profit
so if you can make your little in and
out money just do it
right because i don't feel comfortable
with any stock unless
when you look at the balance sheet their
assets
are greater than their debt
i